Listen, I have my younger son. Who's younger than my daughter. Uh,
once came up to me and I did a sad truth clip on it on my channel,
where he saw something. I can't remember the exact details,
but it was something like the future is female, male toxicity,
toxic masculinity.
And he was sitting with me watching and he kind of looked at me and I don't
remember his exact words,
but he said something like daddy are our boys really bad.
It was really with the innocence of a young child.
And imagine that you are in calculating to half the world's
population known as boys, this kind of pathological stage,
right? You're pathologizing masculinity. It's grotesque. We could,
we could be feminists in the truest sense of the term and the Christina Huff
summer sense of the word without being pathologizing,
half of the world called boys.
What do you think.
We'll take truly to get us past this, that,
that seems to be the next step of this conversation. Okay. We,
we talked about it for a while. We understand it.
Now the masses see a problem, but,
but what is the thing beyond just the courage part? I mean, what,
what would be a societal way to actually put some of this stuff behind us?
So certainly having sort of a cataclysmic, you know,
Savior's Trump come along,
but the reality is Trump is only is going to be out either in a few months or in
a few years.
So you can't just rely on Trump because he ended critical race theory.
Then the problem that idea pathogens is going to go away forever,
but you certainly need.
My dad. I, I thought he's never,
I thought he's never going to step down and he's going to be president until 20,
64 or something I could have. I thought.
Exactly. Uh, so,
so certainly having someone who was able to come from the outside and
redress, many of these things is great, but I truly think it's a long game.
You know, war there has to be involvement.
So I'll give you an example. My, my, uh, one of my children, her,
her science teacher has a BLM sign as an avatar.
So I could do one of two things at that point. I could say, well, forget it.
Or I could write politely, right? Without being too bombastic,
without engaging in all sorts of gathering items, you know, cutting satire,
I could write to her politely and say, you know,
is it appropriate for a science teacher who is educating my young child to
espouse a particular position? What if we don't agree with this position? Right?
So I can, at that point, I have a bifurcation.
I can either get involved or not get involved that has to happen
300 million times a day in every interaction. And every exchange,
if that happens, the wall of will collapse quickly.
If it doesn't, it will be a long drawn out needless war.
So this is why I implore people get engaged. Your voice matters.
It's not only up for D two Dave Rubin to the course of culture.
Each of you is important.
So obviously I have to ask you, did you ask the teacher to do anything?
I know you, I know we all pick our spots. We pick our fights.
What what'd you do?
I haven't, I haven't yet because you know,
my wife was worried that I might engage in some sort of cutting positions
that might not be modulated well enough.
And that might cause sort of a retribution about that.
So in that particular case, I've yet to do it,
but I can tell you that my daughter has often come up to me and said, daddy,
the BLM is still up.
So I think she's kind of almost egging me to get involved and in a sense,
look by my children being around me and seeing the positions that I take.
That's one of the ways by which I fight, right?
So if I do that and you do that with your children, he does that with this,
by the way, the, the,
the cretins are always trying to introduce the idea pathogens ever saw
earlier. So it starts with the universities. Then we go to the high schools.
Then we go to the elementary is because the best time to reach a mind to make it
as malleable as you can is when it doesn't have the cognitive defenses to
protect itself against the idea of pathogens. But by the way,
she's the one who made the joke yesterday.
She was eating something during Kapoor. And she said, well, don't worry, daddy.
I self identify as, as right.
So this little child who has heard my satire was able to construct
that satirical moment.
I, I was told a story by a friend of mine who has a five-year-old that in,
you know, the school year just started.
And that one of the parents sent around a note, uh, to the,
to the other parents in the class that the boy biological boy,
uh, he's a boy at home, but wants to be a girl at school. And they,
so they want everyone to refer to him as whatever the girl name is the female
name at school, but then he goes home and he's a boy again and again,
without this is not mocking trans people or anything like that,
but it's sort of the way it all spills over so that that everyone else has to
behave the way you want them to behave.
But also could this possibly have come from the five-year-old.
I want to be a girl at school, but a boy at home. Like,
it doesn't really sound like that.
And, and listen, I have my younger son who's younger than my daughter, uh,
once came up to me and I did a sad truth clip on it,
on my channel where he saw something. I can't remember the exact details,
but it was something like the future is female, male toxicity,
toxic masculinity.
And he was sitting with me watching and he kind of looked at me and I don't
remember his exact words, but he said something like,
daddy are our boys really bad.
It was really with the innocence of a young child.
And imagine that you are in calculating to half the world's
population known as boys, this kind of pathological stage,
right? You're pathologizing masculinity. It's grotesque. We could,
we could be feminists in the truest sense of the term and the Christina Huff
summer sense of the word without being pathologizing.
Half of the world called boys.
Yeah. I know Jordan wrote a blurb.
Jordan Peterson wrote a bur a blurb for the book. Um,
that's really what he was hitting on more than anything else. Right? I mean,
he was trying to, well, I can't say more than anything else,
but in conjunction with many other big things that,
that you can't say to all these ways, you're inherently evil.
And now he's been gone for a year and a half. And I think a lot of people are,
are lost without that.
Yeah. And I, I got to say, since he is a common friend, when I wrote to Jordan,
it was for, to get him there, to get from him, the endorsement for the book.
It was literally at the worst possible time when he was going through all his
stuff. And he writes right back to me and says,
you are literally the first person I'm responding to. You know,
since opening my laptop, this is the kind of friendship that matters, right.
Jordan and I can disagree on some things. We disagree on young.
We disagree on it. But even if we disagree on points a and B,
when it comes to going into the trenches together,
you want to have guys who have your back and at his lowest moment,
he was willing to take time. So love the diet.
Dad,
are you telling me that academic people could have different beliefs come to
different conclusions and not try to get each other fired or kicked out of the
university or out of all the social clubs?
Incredible. Isn't it? Who knew.
It's, it's just bizarre. Uh, what else can the, can the average person do?
I mean, that, that to me is where this all comes together.
The average guy you're at, I mean,
because of what it always comes down to also is the person going forget the
tenured part that you talked about it, whatever.
And that certain people's makeup isn't to be combative,
but just the person who's going, you know, I'm, I'm just at whatever my job is,
you know, I'm a decent, hardworking person. I've got kids,
I've got all these other responsibilities. And for me to,
to do that little jump, even though I think most people agree with you,
most people heard what you said, and they go, well,
if 300 million people all did at once,
we really could change something overnight. Um, but in their own life,
they just can't do it. Are there any other tricks? Cause this,
this is a question I get all the time.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, so in chapter eight, the last chapter,
I do have a set of prescriptions. I, the chapter is called call to action.
So I'll give you a few. One of them does address the fact that you said, Oh,
some of them are not combative.
The reality is you can't have your values and principles murdered and raped
without ever being combative. If,
if I'm walking down the street with my wife and three guys come to re gang rape
her, I can't say, sorry, sorry, sweetie. I'm not combative. So good luck. Right?
So I have two.
And then one of the prescriptions I have is activate your inner Honeybadger.
Now, the reason why, again, I use this animal comparison because Honeybadger is,
don't give an F right, honey badgers. You can have a, a,
a pride of lions, six lines. You could go on on YouTube and see those clips.
You can have six lines approach. A honey Honeybadger is the size of Emma.
May she rest in peace, a small, a small dog.
And the response will be so ferocious that the six,
six lines will look at each other and go, what the hell?
I don't want part of this. Right?
So you can't really fight in a war in this case,
a war of ideas without ever triggering your EIR without ever being indignant.
So you can't be passive. You can't be castrated.
So unfortunately you have to at once, once in a while be kebabs.
So activate your inner honeybees.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about academia,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our academia playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.